[Music]
in this video we'll show you how to
build a server-less real-time credit
card fraud detection solution
using google cloud my name is paul
longlin a developer advocate for google
cloud
and together with quantify a gcp premier
partner
we co-developed a design pattern to help
you accelerate building a fraud detected
solution with google cloud
i'm nishant thyagi i'm a senior business
analyst at quantify
i am pawan kumar and i'm a senior cloud
engineer at quantify
let's first talk about fraud detection
in the industry
what does quantify see broad detection
is a major concern for many businesses
and financial services
global losses from payment fraud have
tripled in the last 10 years
in the uk alone for every 100 pounds
spent using credit cards
7.5 pence was lost to fraud so the
challenge is
to build and manage a real-time crowd
detection solution at sky
so in this video we'll show you how to
build a real-time fraud detection
solution
broken down into the following sections
how to prepare the training data in
bigquery
how to build the fraud detection model
directly within bigquery using bigquery
ml
how to build a pipeline to do real-time
model predictions
using data flow how to set up
alert-based notifications
when fraud is detected using pubsub
and how to create interactive dashboards
for business and technical operations
using data studio and the code and
instructions to follow this design
pattern are all linked in the video
description below
let's talk about preparing the training
data in bigquery
to detect if a transaction is fraud or
not you want to have information on the
transaction and the customer's
information
so normally these historical records are
in separate tables
you may have one table for transactions
and another to keep track of your
customers demographic information
but to make it easier to show you here
we have combined both of the data sets
into a single table for training
this table is going to be our training
data where each row is a transaction
that occurred in the past
containing details of the transaction
and some customer
information each column is a feature
such as
what time the transaction occurred what
the merchant was
category and so on there's also a label
feature
called his fraud which is a value of 1
r0
this is what the model will then trying
to predict a probability of fraud
between 0 and 1
the data here is simulated data so you
can replace this with your own real data
for your needs
could you elaborate on your choice of
bigquery here it's an extremely scalable
data warehouse
it's fast and easy to use and we find
that customers choose bigquery because
you get the best of enterprise great
data storage
data analytics machine learning all in
one place
we have customers storing terabytes of
data in bigquery
and they have the capability to train
machine learning models
within bigquery directly so speaking of
machine learning
the next step is building the machine
learning model to detect fraud
using bigquery ml perhaps the magic of
bigquery ml
is that without needing to move your
data out of bigquery
using bigquery ml you can train and
deploy machine learning models
directly using sql and you don't have to
procure or maintain
extra infrastructure because it uses
bigquery's built-in
auto-scaling infrastructure to handle
model training and deployment
at scale and at quantify we find our
customers really enjoy being able to use
the democratized ml capabilities which
allow
analysts to run machine learning models
using sql
so with the training data we can train a
model using just sql with bigquery ml
while there are several classification
algorithms available to choose from
with bigquery ml like logistic
regression deep neural networks and
automl tables
we find that xg boost models worked
really well with minimal hyperparameter
tuning required
making it easy to build good models
quickly so in the create model statement
we give the model a name like simple
model set the model type to
booster tree classifier for xc boost set
the input label calls
to each fraud as the label of 0 or 1
that we want to predict and then select
the training data
you can also adjust some hyper
parameters such as
num parallel tree and max iterations for
example we were able to train this model
within just 10 minutes over 1.3 million
rows and 10 features
which is really fast considering there
is no need to set up extra
infrastructure to train the model
now i noticed that you called the model
simple model
could you elaborate on that a little bit
yes in practice just looking at the
transactional data
and the customers demographics like what
country they are in
and their age is actually very likely to
be insufficient to produce a strong
performing
fraud detection model so what would you
recommend then to build a good fraud
detection model
well there are many ways one way which
we can show
in this design pattern is to do more
feature engineering by also looking at
the customer's historical
activity if someone typically spends on
average hundred dollars per month on
their credit card
and this transaction shows you are
spending two thousand dollars
then that might be unusual so you would
want the model to pick
up on this by adding in relevant
features and this is perhaps just a
starting point
in reality you may want to have a lot
more features and
you may want to improve your model in
other ways like model selection
hyper parameter tuning or model assembly
which are all possible with bigquery ml
because there are so many approaches
depending on the data available in the
exact scenario
in this design pattern we just show you
how you can get started with a few extra
aggregate features of the customer
activity
such as how long it's been since their
last transaction
the average spend on the credit card per
week or per month
and also the number of transactions of
average in the last 24 hours
just as examples of what you could do
with the models built in bigquery ml
could you show us how you evaluate the
models you can see the evaluation matrix
directly on the bigquery ui under the
evaluation tab
you can see the log loss rbc auc
precision recall accuracy f1 score and
other visualizations as well
to actually compare f1 score request
models you can use
select star from ml dot evaluate and
then the model name
you can do this for both the models and
combine the results using union on
to compare metrics you can use f1 score
and roc auc
where the higher the values are the
better the model performs
for imbalanced data sets like in credit
card fraud where you have mostly normal
transactions
then we recommend using the f1 score to
compare the models
and indeed if you look at the model that
uses aggregate behavioral data
the f1 score is 0.78 versus the simple
models f1 score of 0.56
so it's improved dramatically by
incorporating the historical data
although there is a room for model
improvement as discussed earlier
we'll just use this second model to
demonstrate how you can use a bigquery
ml model
like this one in a streaming pipeline
for real-time floor detection
with a model built let's talk about
making predictions to detect fraud
now for predictions there is batch and
online predictions
could you elaborate on the differences
sure for batch predictions this is when
you want to make predictions on lots of
data in bulk
at a time which you can do in bigquery
ml with select star from
ml.predict your model and the data you
want to make predictions on
batch predictions are useful in making
large amounts of predictions in a single
shot
and you can do this with bigquery ml but
they are not optimized for real-time
inference
where you may have lots of predictions
you need to do per second
so that's where online prediction comes
in which is for real-time predictions in
low latency situations
for higher frequencies of predictions to
do online predictions
you will need to export and host the
bigquery ml model on ai platform
another way to export the model for
online predictions
is instead of hosting the model on ai
platform as its own
endpoint you can similarly export to
google cloud storage
but serve it directly in a dataflow
pipeline
this may be helpful if you want to
optimize for lower average latency
but it may also make model
maintainability a little bit more
difficult
so in this design pattern we'll just
show you how the model is hosted
as its own endpoint on ai platform for
online predictions
so pavon how does that work you can
easily do it via two steps
step one export the model to a cloud
storage location
by running bqextract command with the
model name
and the destination location as
arguments
step 2 once it's in cloud storage you
will need to create a model on air
platform
which can hold one or more versions of
the model
so the next step is to create a model
version by running the gcloud
a platform versions create command
providing the
gcs location of the previously exported
model from bigquery ml
and then to make predictions you can
send a request to the deployed model
using the gcloud ai platform predict
command by passing in the transaction
data
so with the model hosted the next step
is putting it together into a pipeline
that can handle transactions in real
time make predictions
and then send notification alerts for
fraud
to create the pipeline you can build a
data flow pipeline with the following
elements
first it ingests new transactions from a
pub sub subscription
pubsub is an event messaging service so
the pub sub subscription is waiting for
any new transactions to come in
as essentially json messages as a new
transaction is ingested
data flow then does a lookup on the
customer's historical activity
to do some aggregations the lookups can
be stored on something like firestore
which is a serverless nosql database
with the combined data dataflow then
invokes the floor detection model on ai
platform
and gets a response with the probability
that it's fraught between 0
and 1. the prediction outputs are then
stored in a separate table in bigquery
and in parallel data flow also triggers
a notification to a pub sub topic
which can then trigger any downstream
notifications when it comes to detecting
fraud in real time
what is the latency that you get with
this pipeline
from the incoming transaction to the
notification
and what do you typically see your
customers asking for in terms of
their required latency for some of our
customers the detection has to typically
occur
within seconds for it to be effective in
this pipeline the latency between
when a transaction occurs and when the
fraud notification is sent is around two
to eight seconds
which falls in line with what we see
institutions asking for
and what if customers need much lower
latency
the first way is instead of hosting the
model as an end point on ai platform
you can see decreases in latency by
exporting the model in google cloud
storage
and serve the predictions directly from
data flow
as mentioned earlier however
if you still want to keep the model
endpoint as is
on ai platform then you can try to
upgrade the machine type
increasing the number of nodes for model
serving
or increasing the quota limit on ai
platform predictions
and what about data flow we find that
flow is really
easy to use and scalable it can auto
scale on its own
so you don't need to worry about the
streaming infrastructure needed to run
these pipelines
uh could you walk us through a demo
certainly
let me show you how this works on google
cloud platform
starting with ingesting the transactions
first
let's verify that we have a live stream
of new messages
coming in via pub sub as real-time
transactions
you can view some of these transactions
by clicking on view messages here
as you can see each message holds
transaction details like
the transaction date amount merchant
information
and user demographics required for the
ml model to do a prediction
but where is the aggregate data of
customer activity
since aggregate data relies on
historical activity
it should be computed on the fly in real
time
let's check that on faster we are using
firestore to store the users
recent transactions and look these up
very quickly
to compute aggregates on the recent
activity
the data flow pipeline will run these
aggregations
for the user for example calculating
volume
or transaction frequency and then
add that to the raw transaction data we
saw from pub sub
at the same time data flow will also
update this
firestore record to only maintain the
most recent transactions required
for future computations
so let's take a look at the dataflow
pipeline
this is our streaming dataflow pipeline
consuming real-time transactions from
pub sub
converting them into json format doing a
lookup to firestore to pitch the
historical activity
computes aggregations inbox ml models
deployed on ai platform
to get the probability of fraud and once
the prediction is done
it will send alert notifications
automatically to pubsub
so that downstream processes can be
integrated
at the same time it also stores output
predictions
from the fraud detection model into a
bigquery table
so how does the output prediction look
like
the column is fraud model with
aggregates is the predicted output
with value 1 being a fraud transaction
and 0 being a genuine one
notice how the number of rows here
increases from 12 000
to almost 13 000 as new transactions are
processed
and then stored here in bigquery so
sean what's the next step keeping an eye
on how everything is working using
dashboards is really useful at this
point
so first here's a dashboard we created
for business users
so as a business user i may ask a
question of
where are all the fraud transactions
occurring you can see it broken down by
merchant type
you can also see it broken down by
geography and you can even click on
specific parts on the map
to filter for transactions only in the
state of illinois
and another question may be how is the
rate of fraud detection changing over
time
in these graphs you can see the
fraudulent transactions over a period of
time
and identify the average fraud
percentage on specific days
next we also created this dashboard for
a technical team to monitor the health
of the pipeline
track the incoming transactions monitor
the output from individual components
and supervise the output notification
channel and
what data is this dashboard built off of
this dashboard uses data from cloud
operations
which collects metrics logs and traces
across google cloud and our applications
by visualizing this data in a dashboard
it allows a technical user to monitor
model latency
as well as the volume of fraud
notifications going through data flow
and pops up if there are unusual peaks
or any lines seems to be dropping to
zero when they shouldn't
then that would tell us that something
perhaps is wrong that the technical team
needs to address
so if you'd like to know more about the
solution or want to see the code
follow the links in the video
description to the public code
repository
and with that now you should know how to
build a real-time credit card fraud
detection solution
on google cloud thank you onify for your
expertise as a gcp partner
and thank you all for watching